severe weather and snow and ice threaten
90 million Americans this morning a
system that brought rough snowy
conditions to Oklahoma and Missouri
pelted Texas covering it and a sheet of
ice is now moving east
oh no CBS News meteorologists and
climate specialists Geoff Barrow daily
reports the system brought a different
kind of danger to the Gulf states a
powerful and scary tornado caught on
camera in Mississippi just one of
several twisters ravaging parts of the
state on Wednesday leaving a path of
destruction for miles crews are out in
force working to repair those downed
power lines and to clear roads which are
scattered with debris drone video shows
the damage inside of this home right
near the city of Jackson a teenager
inside the home survived by sheltering
in a bathtub dangerous storms also
slamming Louisiana where high winds
brought down scaffolding in New Orleans
and that crushed several cars one person
was hurt in Indiana
heavy snow blanketed parts of the state
with near whiteout conditions on the
roads
snow and ice also causing this crash it
happened on a bridge that crosses over
the Missouri River traffic there shut
down for hours and the big story today
severe weather again in the southeast
the possibility of tornadoes and the
reason why a huge contrast between cold
air to the west and warm air to these
it's been very warm so far this winter
in the southeast you can see the wide
view this is where the severe weather is
now especially in portions of Alabama
look at it in 3d and some of those tops
extending up to 45,000 feet the higher
the tops but worse and more dangerous
the storms are you can see as we swirl
around a lot of these storms are serious
because of that we have a tornado watch
it's in effect for the panhandle of
Florida parts of Georgia and also into
Alabama we take this through later today
and the worst of the weather approaching
the coast Charleston Jacksonville 25
million plus under the threat for
tornadoes northern side of the system
the warm air punches all the way up to
the Canadian border that's where the
rain is headed on the western side a
decent amount of snow in Buffalo and
Pittsburgh and guys once again it is
rain and not snow here in the big cities
in the Northeast and you have one very
depressed weatherman who would like a
blizzard yeah
Jeff bird Ellie trying to ruin our
weekend